good
afternoon my name is jeff todd with
wolfram research and my talk today is
going to be on enterprise deployment
technologies
so let's jump right in so what are we
going to be discussing today
uh we're going to be talking about
options for deploying your wolfram
language code
we'll be talking about when each
deployment option makes the most sense
and also some in industry use cases for
these deployed technologies
uh we'll also talk a little bit at the
end about how to get started for these
technologies that maybe
sound good to you i also would advocate
going to a follow talk at 3 30
on developing with wolf from enterprise
private cloud by my colleague joel klein
and i'll mention that again at the end
of the talk
so the wolfram deployment options i'm
going to be talking about today are the
wolfram enterprise license with
enterprise cdf and notebook the cdf file
type
is soon to be replaced by notebook so if
you see it go away
i'm sure you'll see things to that that
aspect but um that's what's
happening so it's going to be called no
longer the free cdf player it's already
the free wolfram player
um so just a slight note on that we'll
be talking about the wolfram engine
which is a new offering from us
and then wolfram enterprise private
cloud if i have time i will talk briefly
about wolfram application server but i
know that my colleague jill klein
will also be talking a little bit about
it in his talk
so first i think i wanted to talk about
why deploy in wolfram
um i think there are a lot of advantages
to deployment in wolfram a lot of them
are the same advantages for why you work
in wolfram language the first is that
it's the fattest fastest prototyping and
development language available
um you know the super functions the meta
algorithms
we provide a progressively higher level
environment every release
for being able to do work efficiently
and quickly and we'll see some examples
in the use cases where that ties
directly into
why they wanted to choose wolfram and
use us as their platform
also it's mostly connected to almost
everything obviously
new things come about and we are working
furiously to continue to connect to
everything we can
but from databases 180 plus different
file formats
apis other programming languages the
internet of things
we try to make it as flexible and useful
for you as a programming language
to maintain that connectivity and then
lastly the integrated system with access
to hundreds of application areas
so the fact that mathematica is not just
about math the wolfram language is not
just about math it's about
building on three decades of development
across machine learning and neural nets
and image processing and
visualization geometry and data science
all kinds of different areas
that give you a lot of flexibility and
power when you're working
on handling complex solution solutions
especially in today's world
i think it's important to note that we
we develop horizontally and vertically
so that we can provide you with a
flexible and powerful language
you know on the right hand side are a
lot of different tools that you might be
familiar with and even use
on the left hand side is really just our
documentation demonstrating that we have
a lot of
analogous functionality to many of these
third-party packages
and if we can help you limit the amount
of third-party packages that you would
have to use in your solutions that's
another great reason
why developing and deploying in the
wolfram language can be a great thing
save you a bunch of time and there will
be some use cases where that came
directly was relevant to their case we
also evolve with every content release
as many of you know
the fact that you're here at the wolfram
technology conference probably means
that you've
been with us for a while or at least had
interest in a while
and so it's every release for us the
content releases are not just a handful
of charts and graphs and a couple new
pieces of documentation
as many of you already know it's entire
broad areas hundreds potentially
of calcul functions in image processing
parallel computation iot
machine learning neural nets new
burgeoning areas uh bleeding edge
technology that we come out with and so
uh
basing your uh deployment on our
language
means that you will be getting a steady
stream and supply of new functionality
along the way
that should hopefully be useful to you
as as
technology advances so let's jump right
into the first
development deployment technology which
is enterprise cdf or
notebook zoom for those of you who have
never seen a cdf
uh or understand you know what that
really means what we mean by enterprise
cdf
is kind of like what you're looking at
here it's an interface using a lot of
the user interface
gui functions that are available in
wolfram one of the things that you would
provide
is immediate results so a lot of times
you want to provide an interactive
report an interactive
tool or an application to someone where
they are able to
walk through the computations that
you've created the models the algorithms
the data that you want them to look at
and visualize and it gives them not only
a way to do that
you could do that in a static document
like a pdf but it gives them a way to
move and migrate through the various
models the data the computations and
make what-if scenario kinds of questions
so you can see here with this sort of
example of a retirement calculator
um you know there are various things
most of us are probably familiar with
this
um you know on the on the internet you
can go in and just log into something
that looks very much like this
um and who knows it might be powered by
some kind of a cloud-based or or wolfram
product
but as you move the sliders back and
forth you can see things change in real
time
and that's kind of what the nature of
the cdf uh enterprise cdf
uh goes to and we'll we'll talk a little
bit about what makes the difference
between a regular free cdf
and an enterprise edf there are also
standalone documents that include
computation
and the computational power is all built
into the document that you're providing
to people
and we'll show a couple of you cases
that will highlight you know why that
is really great and important so what is
a wolfram enterprise license
so wolfram enterprise is a class of
license that allows you to generate what
we call
enterprise cdfs computable document
format or enterprise notebooks
the enterprise cdf or notebook can be
opened viewed and used within the free
will from player that anyone
can download as the only required run
time there's no purchase
and so the model is that the author you
would use the enterprise license to
create these active
uh interactive applications reports and
then offer those up to your consumers
and those consumers might be management
might be colleagues it might be friends
it might be customers there's a wide
variety of
who those consumers might be as well as
the type of thing that you might want to
deploy to them
so examples could be engineers might
want to develop a specific or
proprietary application within their
organization
a lot of times that i've found these are
living uncomfortably in excel in today's
world
they are often you know kind of clued
together excel is not a great
environment for that
to take place and so having wolfram and
enterprise cdf as an alternative to that
as a way of deploying these
more complex and sophisticated models is
a great thing
data scientists may want to deploy
interactive reports or dashboards to
management to better visualize and
understand
but as well as explore and interrogate
the data and concept and models
this goes i think many of you have been
in those meetings i definitely can
understand that workflow where you see
some example that you've worked up data
analytics some kind of data science
result
and some manager or colleague is asking
a question about this that or the other
and if that's just a static report then
that means we'll talk about it next week
if it's a enterprise cdf that means we
can talk about it right now
we can move these sliders we can push
these buttons we can see the effect on
those live computations
we can see the charts and graphs change
in real time so it's it's a really
progressive and a great way to help
visually
convey the concepts and decisions that
you're making
lastly departments may want to develop
tools for their members that could be
sales people or marketers or engineers
or scientists
utilize out in the field on uh where
they work or to customers or to deliver
to clients
there's a wide variety of what you might
want to create with an enterprise cdf
so one question i often hear is well i
already have mathematical from one
and i can export cdfs and notebooks now
so what's the difference
well the free cdf that can come out of
what we call a mathematica standard
license
has some limitations and those on this
list are sort of denoted by the
lower right hand corner under enterprise
cdf and that is an
enterprise cdf you can import and export
live data so i can bring in new data to
a cdf whereas with a free cdf i'm not
able to
i have to encapsulate all the data that
i would want to show someone in that
initial cdf i give to them
it also allows you to link to additional
languages java are things of that nature
and enterprise cdf where you can't do
that kind of linking in the free cdf
same with source code encryption with an
enterprise cdf i may be deploying
algorithms that are sensitive or
proprietary to my organization i may be
giving a tool
that uses those algorithms to a customer
and i don't want that customer to be
able to see that or reverse engineered
or know what i'm doing
and so i can encrypt those enterprise
cdfs and then lastly custom dialogs and
other spawn documents really what that
kind of means is
you have arbitrary input that you're
able to put in not just
integers but it could be text it could
be drag and drop an image it could be a
sound file it could be
loading in an excel file it could be all
kinds of expressions that i want to
include and give the user the ability to
bring those in as well as spawn
documents so i want to be able to create
a pdf or a jpeg or
a text file or some kind of thing out of
this tool that i've created in
enterprise cdf
so one thing to those who are not
familiar with wolfram and with some of
the wolfram underlying functionality i
just
very quickly wanted to talk about
manipulating dynamic
er because you're going to see a lot of
use cases and those use cases are going
to
be you're going to see these interfaces
so very quickly i want to highlight that
in wolfram language um you know we've
developed a way where i can have a
function like plot the sine of x
and i get this nice two-dimensional sine
wave i could use a function like table
and i can get a variety of those waves
but back in 2007 we created manipulate
and manipulate allows you to
parameterize
any part of really any equation any
model any algorithm
and be able to give that parameter some
reasonable range
and then you're rewarded with an
interface that i can
move my my widget i can control it in
this case it's a slider but it might be
a drop down menu it might be a radio
button
but you can see that in real time i can
make these changes and and
the visualization updates in real time
and this is very useful for people who
are used to using applications obviously
as a deployed technology
because i can simulate and create these
kinds of things and also
just so you know when you see these
kinds of interfaces later you'll know
that
you know it's not thousands of lines of
code to create that
in some cases it might only be one two
three four lines of code
in the same way you can use dynamic to
very quickly and easily create sort of
nested uh functions that create you know
an input field here and then a result
where
you can give the user um the ability to
type in kind of whatever they want
and be able to get out a
result and that is very useful as well
because as a developer you can't always
know
everything that the user might want to
be able to put in there so giving them
the freedom to be able to put in what
they want
can be largely very effective so i
thought we'd start with a fun use case
which was my 2010 ncaa basketball
tournament bracket application
uh this was my first application i ever
wrote in wolfram language uh
it was developed right after the ability
to sign cds was
you could do that out of your license
you didn't have to upload it to the
wolfram website for people that remember
those days
and it was also the days when we still
had an nc a double-a basketball
tournament to watch
so uh good times uh uh in 2010.
the uh i was actually very impressed
this is this is literally just
copy and pasted from the notebook that i
used to create this um but as you can
see you know i had tabs that you can
walk through i have all my teams i can
pick
um you know resetting brackets and
making these various choices
um obviously these are just all
constructs that are part of the language
that i you know
programmed to be able to you know show
me the visualization of the school
i could pick you know two of these teams
in this area and click on a button
and have it compare those two teams and
all their various stats and tell me
which one i should probably go for
uh this probably has been true for a
long time um
but i was very impressed that uh one
thing that was very helpful to me uh is
you can take this
you can put this into a new notebook so
it's just by itself
we'll paste that in there and then i can
go to file in my mathematic and i have
an enterprise license right now and i
can do preview for wolfram player
so if i've created an interface and i
want to see what this will look like for
my people that i'm going to be giving it
to i can use that
and then i can come back here and see
that everything is behaving correctly
i can make these same kind of
determinations i can see that the pop-up
windows are all working
i can see that it populates correctly
when i make all these choices
i could see maybe some of these other
buttons are working so and so forth i
was just very impressed
that this document 10 years later works
without me having to change one single
thing
into this technology so hopefully that
shows the backwards compatibility that
you can expect
out of uh wolfram animal from technology
so on to more real world cases uh so the
first one is
chicago bridge and iron cbni which is
now part of mcdermott
became known for designing engineering
and field
uh construction of large scale storage
tanks
really huge process vessels and steel
plate structures
these are the kinds of things that when
you see them you kind of wonder how man
would make
such a thing they use enterprise cdf and
notebooks to provide tools to over 500
of their engineers
the cdfs that they use generally
surround proprietary engineering related
tasks
that are associated with their large
scale builds and i've seen
everything from you know how to fit the
appropriate amount of plates around some
gigantic sphere
as well as accounting for weight and all
that kind of thing as well as how to
wrap stairs efficiently to be able to
uh you know go up without a needlessly
endangering said technician that needs
to get on top of these gigantic
uh monstrosities um in this case uh the
example that they were uh
nice enough to send over um was related
to a cone cylinder intersection layout
the thing about this is used by
detailers they obtain plate layout
dimensions and then determine the plate
cutout
obviously they can't show the entire
application because there's a lot of
proprietary stuff in there
one of the things that i like to
highlight though is with enterprise cdf
and notebooks
you're able to create in this case you
know the the logo their own kind of
color scheme
they've got some nice drop down menus
that you know have about getting started
linked to documentation there's a lot of
great tools that give you the ability to
kind of customize and create
the user interfaces and in this case you
can kind of see what i was talking about
before
we have these input fields that they've
obviously nested in here
and as well as with the output that
would be expected so the consumer of
this deployed technology doesn't need to
know anything about wolfram they don't
need to know anything about code
they're just taking the hard work that
you've created and using a very easy to
use interface
and obtaining those results and then
sort of building on what we had talked
about before with the difference between
a free cdf and an enterprise cdf
would be with generating this
engineering report you know it's a
summary of the user input and it
generates a report and in this case i've
got two buttons here
the notebook and excel so i can generate
this out as a mathematic or a wolfram
language notebook
or i can generate this out as an excel
document and i think that's you know
very useful
to be able to create tools that will not
only work with our own technology
but will give people tools they need to
be able to go on to a next step and that
next step very well
well be that they need to deliver
something in excel or text file or a csv
file
or a jpeg to someone that is the result
of the work they've done in this
cdf the next enterprise cdf i want to
talk about is from assured flow
so sureflow works in the oil and gas
area they help companies basically
efficiently extract and manage the flow
of oil and gas
to minimize the environmental impact and
also to maximize revenue
and the safety in their labs and
engineering and tech services
so they use the enterprise cdf as well
as engine as well as cloud
in the delivery of analytic tools in an
easy to use application style
environment and rather than me tell you
about how great it is and everything i
thought i would share just a snippet of
a video from andrew ewell um talking
about uh why they like to use it
i think it comes in a lot on the back
end of that is analyzing that data
post-processing that data doing
you know extra calculations on top of it
and just
having a tool that allows me to
manipulate data
a lot of data at one time is really
valuable
kind of the heart of what we tried to do
with it i think is solve a problem that
a lot of businesses face and that
that was basically how do you capture
your company's intellectual property in
a in a consistent and maintainable way
and what we ended up using was the
wolfram language to do exactly that we
have a project that we call alex
and it was basically our attempt to try
to capture
all of our previous knowledge that was
in the form of spreadsheets
and maintain it so that it was
consistent and
that people knew exactly where they
could go to reach a particular
type of calculation that they wanted
how i use the wolfram language um daily
it's i use
um things like eclipse for the pure sort
of development
and then we're more and more starting to
use the cloud as well we'll send
calculations to
to one another i'll send something to a
colleague
we even use the cloud api to build
small little applications that our
clients can can utilize the wolfram
language
on the backend without necessarily
knowing that that's what they're doing
[Music]
it's the ability to write you know one
line of code that'll accomplish 10
things at once and
and if you've ever tried to do something
like that in excel you can't many times
tools like the wolfram language offer a
really powerful
alternative to things like excel and i
think that if people were willing to you
know
spend a little bit of time learning what
is out there and what it's capable of i
think those benefits really pay off
thank you andrew
so these are briefly uh some of the
images that he was showing um
in that of the alex this is all in the
cdf player you can kind of see up here
the the cdf player but you can also see
they did a very nice job of of making
this their own and having their own nice
aesthetic
and having a really great you know
delineation of the different tools they
can choose along with the tool that
would come up
for their engineers to use so i thought
this was a great tool
and a great use case last use case for
enterprise cdf
enterprise cdfs allow you to inform the
audience kind of through rich
visualizations and live computations
and allows them to ask these questions
of the data the model the scenario
and kind of show people why we're making
decisions that we are and so
i that made me think of agilis energy
which is now part of train
train is probably many of you know as an
hvac company you probably know of them
or maybe even have
an air conditioner or furnace in your in
your house angelus first introduced this
tool to train to help their commercial
customers
um understand how to save money by their
energy consumption and perform analytics
that would expose
you know over expenditures and supported
changes in their power usage patterns
and the cdf they created as a tool was
for their sales people
that would give them a variety of ways
to view uh visualizations of the
building energy
weather data things of that nature so
here i just kind of have a
visualization of what that looks like in
this case they were visualizing you know
about a year of data
um in a three-dimensional way of of one
of their commercial properties
and uh they would use this to help show
and convince the managers of those
businesses
that of the behavior because many times
they would say well you should be
changing you don't need to kick on your
furnaces or you don't need to kick on
the air conditioner so early
that we're seeing here you can wait
until this time and many times without
this kind of data without this kind of
visualization without a tool like this
they would get a lot of resistance but
being able to couple the analytics
along with a very easy to understand
easy to use visualization tool
um in an enterprise cdf uh made it very
easy for them to go in and provide them
with a lot of different information
to make their case and in many cases
they would be able to go and save
you know tens or even hundreds of
thousands of dollars for these places
and it was using a really nice interface
that had many different tabs many
different screens many different tools
all coupled together and designed all in
the wolfram language and deployed with
enterprise cdf
so the next technology i want to talk
about is the wolfram engine um
wolfram engine is a relatively new
offering from wolfram so the first
question
would be kind of what is it for so the
wolfram engine is
actually at the heart of many wolfram
technologies in mathematics and wolf
from one and will from alpha
i'm offering up its library of thousands
of built-in functions for use with your
software engineering or reporting or
computing infrastructure you can call a
wolfram engine from a command line
as a script through sockets or through
xero mq you can also call it through
client libraries like python and
java.net and c as well as systems like
excel or jupiter or unity
and so whereas mathematic is used
primarily for interactive computing via
the notebook
the wolfram engine is intended to be
called by other programs using a variety
of communication
interfaces so kind of what is it
designed to do so ultimately the wolfram
engine
supplements and supports your existing
solutions by providing access to its
thousands of built-in functions as well
as your
specifically developed functions that
you've made with the wolfram language
to existing programs or creating
automated workflows so some examples
would be
i want to create a scheduled task that
feeds data into a wolfram engine
and produce a report every morning that
gets emailed out to management i don't i
don't necessarily need a
a front end you know user version of
mathematica to do that i just want an
engine to be able to handle that task
for me
or i have the wolfram engine sit on the
back end of an existing tool
and occasionally being used to apply a
machine learning or image processing or
natural language algorithm
that i developed in the wolfram language
but want to have used in this other
environment
or i want to embed a wolfram engine into
a device like an mri machine
that maybe performs routine predictive
maintenance and diagnostics and reports
issues or errors and warnings to the
owner of the
manufacturer you know these are all
things that the wolfram engine could be
used for
and i have a couple of use cases so
actually assuredflo who we just heard
from um also uses the wolfram engine
so in this case they created a front end
using react
but it makes all the calls from the
wolfram engine so they mentioned we have
a pretty impressive application written
in a react
for the front end but the math and
everything is done and powered by the
wolfram engine behind the scenes
and these were just a couple of of
examples of what those two uh the
interfaces look like that they created
and react
so obviously we have a bunch of input
fields that will be then parsed into
code
and then you know made uh sent over to
the wolfram engine the engine will
compute and then return the results in
the form of graphs in the form of
various output
so it can be a very useful tool to be
able to have just a machine somewhere
that's handling this in an automated
fashion and generate those kind of
reports
a second use case for this would be the
xbox and hololens team at microsoft
where they test computer vision on a
headless server so wolfram engine sits
on a server and it responds to various
calls as they test a variety of
proprietary computer vision algorithms
that are written in the wolfram language
and um i think this is a great use case
because one of the reasons why they use
wolfram is
these algorithms will eventually be
rewritten and likely compiled
for absolute speed when they get moved
into a product like the xbox
but the speed at which you can prototype
the new algorithms and test and refine
and test
in the wolfram language allows them to
refine and perfect those computer
vision algorithms much more quickly and
so one you know obvious use case for a
wolfram engine is
you know we want to use the high level
and and efficient nature of the wolfram
language to do a bunch of our testing
and algorithmic or modeling work until
we get it narrowed down to what we want
best
and then we'll move forward uh with that
and i think that's a great use for for
something like a wolfram engine
so the last technology we're going to
talk about is the wolf from enterprise
private cloud
i'm sure you guys many of you have heard
of the regular public cloud so i know of
wolf from cloud but how is the
enterprise private cloud different or
what is it
um so the epcs what we call the
enterprise private cloud is is the most
modern way for you to deploy
your web-based wolfram language content
in the form of applications or forms or
reports or tools or the fastest way of
deploying
just apis to your many services or
applications or programs
the epc is a self-contained appliance
consisting of a web application that's
installed on a virtual machine running
centos
it includes access to all wolfram cloud
web interfaces
with additional tools for for research
management user authentication
personalization
the epc can be installed on prem which
is usually on a linux box and behind
your firewalls or on an aws
which is hosted by you or hosted by us
the epc
provides you with a centralized you know
file management a web browser based
interfaces for developing and viewing
and sharing notebooks
as well as additional uh features that
you would want
for deploying apis forms manipulate
objects and other interfaces
i know some people are familiar with web
mathematic and they would ask you know
how is epc different so
you know epc is sort of the futurist the
next evolution it's the next generation
um even on this just basic of charts
there's a lot of things you get with the
epc
especially from the the web-based
interactive side
the ability to instantly create
deployments i don't have to manually
write a bunch of stuff
and code and implement in html and have
it be represented
in jsp i can just use functions that
have been designed specifically for this
new technology like
cloud deploy api function form function
things of that nature that allow me to
very quickly create these constructs and
deploy those
obviously the notebooks being able to
have those represented in the web
browser is really important and really
helpful things like wolfram one or
programming lab or mathematica online
are all usable within
an enterprise private cloud which makes
collaboration between employees and
documentation of things that you are
making very
very useful and then of course cloud
storage file management everything you'd
expect to come along with that
is built into the epc and certainly you
know doesn't have anything like that for
web mathematica
so some commonly asked questions about
the epc it doesn't require the internet
it can be installed on a linux
box could be fully installed and
deployed within your internet so some
people are sometimes concerned that
it's always going to be calling out or
needs to talk to wolfram or needs to
talk to the internet
and that's not the case it can also make
connections with databases file systems
programming languages you know kind of
any way
into your technology stack in a variety
of ways that that would bring value
and then the epc has a pool of kernels
you know session kernels deployment
kernels service kernels
um they each do their own thing session
kernels for people who are using you
know the online
web-based environment for developing
deployment kernels for people who
are designing apis designing forms
designing tools where people are
dragging sliders or clicking buttons or
hitting a submit button
and then service kernels for for
dedicated uh tasks or jobs that need to
run at a particular time
so i'm going to skip over that in the
interest of time and just talk about a
handful of use cases so
innova international um you know as a
financial lending company um and it used
to be that small businesses needing
loans would have to wait weeks or months
for a decision
from their provider you know with
pre-qualification steps taking
a long time and even after that there
was no guarantee that uh you would you
would be approved
um and then you know after that you know
it would be
days uh before you'd find out if you
would get the money um but in today you
know ai
can do a lot of that heavy lifting and
so innova created a platform called
colossus
which uses machine learning and
sophisticated decision flows to make
basic operational decisions that are
related to fraud and credit risk and
operations
um and and determining whether customers
are fraudulent or whether their risk
level is
is is of a level where the bank should
accept them or what kind of offer they
should be extended
and this automated platform runs 24 7
serving peaks of 20 000 applicants an
hour all using
wolfram technology on the back end and
this is from a talk they gave several
years ago
basically their process is there's you
know an application it's easy to
complete it's quick
the underwriting the decisioning that
they've designed in their analytic
system is it happens in three to six
seconds
um the advanced analytics that are are
integrated you know
100 algorithms a thousand different
variables 10 years of customer behavior
data
informing all those and then they accept
agreements reviewed online and they move
forward
one of the things that stuck with me the
most was they mentioned you know some of
the metrics from adopting wolf from
for their process using their old system
a model would take an average of one to
one and a half months to deploy in
production
colossus had reduced that to 1.5 to 2
weeks
and then any minor changes they wanted
to make previously would take one to two
weeks and now only took a few hours
so that was a huge a huge efficiency
improvement
and they had been using sas and ruby
moved to only wolfram a language and got
a lot of
value out of that another use case would
be
with pearson they'd written a about eric
schultz um at walla walla community
college along with several other authors
had written an e-book called calculus
it used to be deployed actually in
enterprise cdf
but now eric and pearson have been
moving calculus into a wolfram private
cloud
environment and so if we go here
we can take a look at what that looks
like and i really like this example and
the fine work that eric's been doing
i mean in showcasing how you can use the
cloud to also have documents
um you know kind of live uh interesting
documents where i can
uh click through a marriage of of text
and graphics and manipulate objects and
and different kinds of things
that a user would be able to see and
interact with and so for people who want
to have really great documentation
really good training services
i think this use case is a really great
job of highlighting what's possible
and having a nicely formatted easily
readable easily navigable
interface where there's you know text
related to all the various uh
concepts we're trying to convey as well
as down here just a little bit you know
there's even a couple of areas where i
can i can make selections
you know and change you know the
parameters of these various calculations
um and see those pretty much in real
time which is very helpful so
i'm seeing something deployed in the
wolfram cloud like this um at this level
and
with this complexity uh for this kind of
use cases is really exciting
and then the last use case trying to get
you out here as fast as possible but i
think it'd be great to end on
is actual emerald labs they have a thing
called cloud lab
and basically it's a multi-million
dollar lab that you can remotely
control through wolfram language and
through the cloud you come into an
interface you you click your buttons
you make your choices to run experiments
you you click a button
off goes this remote lab that runs all
of your various
experiments you get back your data and a
bunch of graphs and and uh
analytics options for being able to look
through the data
and i will go ahead and end with a just
a little intro video from them
on that showcasing kind of one of the
better use cases of of the wolf from
cloud
itself
as chemists and biologists we've always
been firmly bound to the laboratory
for us the scope and limitations of
scientific exploration
have been defined by the instruments we
have and the scale of our work has been
metered by the long hours required at
the bench
it's time to change that
[Music]
emerald cloud lab is a remote controlled
life science laboratory
that allows scientists to execute their
experiments without being anchored to a
physical lab
in a cloud lab experiments are driven by
issuing commands over the internet
which are then run in a vast highly
automated central facility
[Music]
with an ecl account you have full
control over every aspect of how your
experiments are conducted
control the transfers of volumes from
less than a microliter to 20 liters
and the transfers of solids with masses
from micrograms to kilograms
[Music]
there are over 100 different models of
best-in-class instrumentation
online at the ecl
[Music]
ecl facilities run your experiments on
demand
24 hours a day 7 days a week 365 days
a year leaving just hours between the
moment you conceive your experiment
and the moment you receive your results
[Music]
it's not unusual for an ecl user to be
orchestrating dozens of protocols
simultaneously
far more than one could ever manage in a
traditional laboratory
[Music]
when you're ready you can build scripts
which automatically execute a series of
experiments of arbitrary complexity
reproduce results or process the data
and generate reports for you to analyze
as chemists and biologists our minds are
capable of moving faster
and further than the laboratory has ever
allowed us
take your seat in the command center
transcend the lab
[Music]
so i thought it was a great use case um
you guys probably recognized a lot of uh
code and the visualizations that there
um so i know we're three minutes over i
really appreciate your time and seeing
today uh if you
are interested if you know anything that
you've seen today and want to have
further discussions
certainly feel free to reach out um with
mathematic enterprise edition you know
you
you can upgrade to that you can get a
new one if you want that wolfram engine
is actually free to download for testing
so feel free to just
search for that or reach out we can get
you hooked up um with uh with that
information
and then the enterprise private cloud
happy to have conversations around that
for anything you're interested
in deploying with that i will let you go
i know there's some 330 classes
happening
um thank you so much for coming and i
appreciate it
have a great day